what
did I
they're one of the deadliest weapons in
the Russian arson
the Shaheed 136 an unarmed Kamikaze
drone made by Iran
frequently deployed by Moscow at
military and civilian Targets in Ukraine
they fly low they're quite small they
were not as easily detectable and not as
easy to shoot down using Conventional
Weapons fearsome formidable and
featuring a Canadian connection a key
Think Tank took apart one such drone
shot down by the Ukrainian military and
found an antenna component made by
Talisman Wireless based in Ottawa in a
statement the company said it's quote
painfully aware their parts are in
Iranian drones adding they absolutely do
not sell any of our products to Iran so
how do Canadian products end up being
used against our allies the Prime
Minister says Talisman is cooperating
with an investigation we have strict
export permits in place for sensitive
technology that are rigorously enforced
and that's why we're going to be
following up with this company Canada
has export sanctions on Iran but unlike
Finnish military products most component
parts like talismans antennas are just
pieces of a larger hole and don't
require Federal approval to be exported
allowing and to get them elsewhere
remember a lot of these small component
cart parts could be easily sold to third
countries elsewhere in the world in
Africa or something like that for
totally legitimate purposes 30 other
western-made components were identified
in the deconstruction from countries
including Japan Germany and the United
States those parts have helped the
shahad 136 take off internationally at a
cost of about twenty five thousand
dollars per drone and a range of 2500
kilometers Russia can cheaply and
effectively dispatch drones into key
Ukrainian infrastructure the majority of
these airstrikes whether they're
missiles or Iranian drones or other
attacks or shelling are hitting
apartment buildings hospitals schools as
well as the energy infrastructure there
have been hundreds of Kamikaze drone
strikes across Ukraine but that slowed
dramatically in recent weeks the
Ukrainian military saying those drones
don't hold up well during the cold
Ukrainian winter Donna all right
Mackenzie gray thank you